como se elige un presidente en colombia
y cuáles son sus funciones
en colombia la constitución ordena que
el presidente y el vicepresidente sean
escogidos en elecciones exclusivas es
decir separadas de las legislativas y
las de autoridades locales gana quien
logre la mitad más uno de los votos y en
caso de que ningún candidato lo consiga
los dos primeros pasan la segunda vuelta
al cabo de tres semanas
este año la primera vuelta fue el pasado
29 de mayo y la segunda tendrá lugar el
19 de junio el periodo presidencial en
colombia es de 4 años y con una reforma
constitucional aprobada en 2015 no
existe la reelección desde la
constitución de 1991 sólo dos
presidentes han sido reelegidos álvaro
uribe en 2006 y juan manuel santos- en
2014 una particularidad de las
presidenciales colombianas es que si el
voto en blanco es mayoritario estas
deben repetirse con candidatos distintos
el presidente en colombia como en otras
democracias de la región tiene amplios
poderes es jefe de estado jefe de
gobierno y autoridad administrativa
suprema además de encabezar las fuerzas
armadas es pedir decretos resoluciones y
decretar estados de excepción también
las leyes se promulgan sólo con su firma
y aquí no termina la lista de poderes el
presupuesto y la mayoría de
nombramientos del poder ejecutivo se
definen desde su oficina un presidente
con amplios poderes pero también con
contrapesos
así es el régimen presidencialista
colombiana
[Música]